cases of coronavirus are rising
yesterday we saw 3542
new cases the highest since the 12th of
april
the variant first identified in india
so called b1617.2
is still spreading and the latest
estimates
are that more than half and potentially
as many as three quarters of all
new cases are now of this variant
now as we set out our roadmap we always
expected
cases to rise we must remain vigilant
the aim of course is to break the link
to hospitalizations and deaths so that
cases alone
no longer require stringent
restrictions on people's lives the
critical thing to watch is the link
from the number of cases to how many
people end up in hospital
the increase in cases remains focused in
hot and we're doing all we can to tackle
this variant
wherever it flares up over the past six
months
we now have built a huge testing
capacity at our disposal
and we're using this to surge
testing into the eight hot spot areas
and in other places where cases are
lower but rising in the hot spot areas
we're
surging vaccines too for those who are
eligible
in bolton for instance we've done 17
147 vaccinations in the last week
all of the available evidence shows that
the best way to protect
yourself your loved ones and your
community
against this new variant is to get both
jabs of the 49 people who are in
hospital
with covert in bolton only five
have had both vaccine doses
and earlier today i spoke to fiona
nowden the chief executive of bolton
hospital
and her message is very clear the
hospital
is functioning well and is open to all
those
who need it but people need to be
careful
and cautious and follow the rules and
take personal responsibility to help to
slow
the spread she also said that and i
quote
i dread to think where we'd be without
the vaccine
so please ask people to come forward and
get the jab
so when you get the call get the jab
and make sure you come forward for your
second dose
so you can get the maximum possible
protection
the vaccine is severing the link between
cases and hospitalizations
and deaths from coronavirus this week's
ons data show that three and four adults
now have covered 19
antibodies including over 90 percent of
people aged 50 and above
and this means that the vast majority of
those most
vulnerable to this virus have that
protection
that antibodies provide but i want to
see those
rates climb further having three in four
adults with antibodies is important but
there's more still
to do and today's data from public
health england
show why this is important they have
estimated that over the last week
the vaccination program has prevented a
further
200 deaths and prevented a further 600
people
from going into hospital bringing these
figures together
it means that in total thirteen thousand
two hundred deaths have been prevented
and thirty nine thousand seven hundred
hospitalizations
by the vaccination program so the case
for getting the jab has never been
stronger and we're putting jabs into
arms as quickly as humanly possible
we've given in fact
4.1 million vaccines over the past week
which is the highest figure since march
and i'm absolutely delighted
to see how this is rolling out in
different parts of the country
thanks to the incredible hard work of
colleagues across the midlands
including andy street the mayor of the
west midlands and nhs colleagues
right across the midlands and so many
others we have today hit the milestone
of
10 million vaccines being delivered
across the midlands
in the southwest of england where i was
earlier this week
visiting vaccination centers as far
flung as the owls of silly
over five million doses have been
delivered
three quarters of adults in the
southwest have now had their first dose
and over half have had both doses
this is the highest proportion in the
country
all in all this rapid progress in the
rollout of vaccines in this race between
the virus and the vaccines
this rapid rollout means that yesterday
we were able to open up vaccinations to
all
those aged 30 and above and i would urge
everybody to come forward
next week i'll be hosting g7 health
ministers
at the health ministers summit in oxford
oxford has been at the cutting edge of
science
during this pandemic they led the
recovery trial that uncovered treatments
that have saved millions of lives across
the world
and of course they developed the oxford
vaccine
which is britain's gift to the world
that has now been deployed without any
profit margin
to 450 million
doses across the world today i can
update you that half a million people
here
have now signed up to our vaccine
registry
research registry the vaccine research
registry is
about having a group of people who are
prepared to take part
in clinical trials and they've signed up
to say that they're
ready and willing to take part and this
is important because our world leading
position
in the discovery of new medicines relies
on these clinical trials
and i'm incredibly grateful to the half
a million people who are all playing
their part
today i can announce further that
together with sepi the global
vaccination effort we funded the
expansion of another important oxford
study
which is the first in the world to look
at whether different vaccines can
safely be used as part of a two dose
regime
using different vaccines and if they can
be mixed
then and they can be mixed without
reducing effectiveness
or indeed mixed and lead to an increase
in effectiveness
then this could have a huge impact on
speedy up vaccination campaigns
all the way across the world and getting
more people the protection
that's needed from this deadly virus it
has the potential to transform
lives globally and it is brilliant
frankly to see that once again research
which is taking place on our shores and
at our universities
is leading the way one of the most
promising areas
of new research is into antivirals the
thing about antivirals is that you can
give them to people
in an area of an of an outbreak for
instance to reduce their chance of
catching covert
if they come into contact with somebody
who has got coveted
so for instance you can use antivirals
to help suppress an outbreak
these antivirals are not yet approved
and the prime minister has set a goal of
having
two available later this year
antivirals can treat people early
preventing mild disease from turning
into something much more serious
and they can use as a prophylactic
preventing
the virus from spreading i'm absolutely
determined that our
antivirals task force will channel the
same
positive can do collaborative spirit
that works so successfully for vaccines
and i'm pleased to be able to announce
that eddie gray
has been appointed as chair eddie brings
a wealth of experience
from his time at gsk and at
dynavax and i know that eddie will make
a huge
contribution at this time of national
need
our response to this pandemic is a
big team effort and eddie's leadership
will help make that team stronger sill
it's this team this collective endeavor
which you've been a part of
that's got us this far but the pandemic
is not yet
over so please keep doing your bit
remember the basics hands face space
and fresh air get your rapid regular
tests
and when you get the call get both jabs
i'll now hand over to dr harry's to talk
through the latest data
in a bit more detail thank you secretary
of state um could i have the first slide
please
so what we can see on this side which
we've seen before is the number of
people
whether this be bilateral flow test or
or pcr test
testing positive for covid19 in the uk
um and of course we can see that there
has been a sustained and sharp decline
in cases
from a peak of over 60 000 in the middle
of january
on towards towards may if i could have
the next slide please
but if we just look at the end of that
tail end of the chart
what you can see here is is a suggestion
of an
upward rise in cases which the secretary
of state has referred to
so these are seven day rolling averages
and the numbers here are up to 2773
cases on that rolling average but you
can see
the latest data at 3500.
now the interpretation of this needs
careful consideration because
as we've described there is surge
testing going out into those areas
which actually have the highest number
of cases and so we are actively finding
many cases which is a good thing we can
break
the chains of transmission but
nevertheless
we do know that in most cases across the
uk now
uh the new variant is taking uh the
event which originates in india is
taking a place of the
117 variant so something that we need to
watch
really carefully but if we go to the
next slide
then we can look at how that translates
into people turning up
in hospital and being admitted with
serious illness
and what we can see here is that the
again the hospital
bed occupation for patients with covid19
has dropped right down very rapidly uh
following to a large extent our
the end of the lockdown measures
significant lockdown measures but also
of course at the same time
that the vaccination programme has
really been pushed out strongly
so on the 25th of may we can see that
there were 915 people
in hospital with with kovid whereas if
we go right back
to middle of january at the peak there
were around four and a half thousand of
missions
every day and we're just going to look
on the next side at the tail end of that
curve
and in contrast currently to the data
that we saw
on actual numbers of cases we can see
that the
patients admitted to hospital has
continued
to decline or flatten off but we are not
seeing
a sharp increase in cases in hospital
admissions
and then if we go on to the next slide
sadly we can see that curve for the
number of people who have
died within 28 days of a positive
covert case and again back in january at
the peak that was sadly over
1 000 a day and when you look at the
tail end of this graph as well you can
see that the most recent seven day
average
uh is is just eight deaths all of them
very sad but a significant decrease
and these are predominantly in uh older
people who
have have not been vaccinated
if you go on to the next night please we
can see that sticking along you can see
that
as usual we have a a variation in
reporting of the deaths often they will
be low at the weekend and rise in the
week so it's
important to look at the recent average
rolling rate but that is now
seven day average is now eight deaths
per day
and then i think on the final slide if
we then just look at
our vaccination rates what we can see
here is the blue line those who've had
first dose only and then catching up
very rapidly
uh those who've had a second dose this
is now over 60 million
individuals and as the secretary of
state has said the latest evidence
suggests that
particularly in relation to the variant
first
identified from india that it is that
second devs which is really important so
we're looking to make sure
that that orange yellow bar keeps
continuing
upwards so everybody go and get your
jabs
thank you very much dr harris the first
questions we'll turn to
are questions from the public and the
first one is from
janet from liverpool by video
hi given the eu are going to relax the
rules for fully vaccinated
visitors by allowing us in with the
vaccine passport
and with no pcr or lateral flow test
requirements
when can we expect the uk to do the same
for returning
uk citizens thank you
thank you janet an important question
and we've set out the principles of
of having international travel
conducted in a safe way through the red
amber and green list
so of course right now you can travel to
a greenless country
and whether or not you've been
vaccinated in fact
and there's of course a testing regime
because we are
vigilant at the border and want to make
sure that
we don't see a big increase in the
number of cases coming from any of the
green list countries
but at the moment they're very low in
the green list countries as they are
here and then obviously we have
more stringent rules for the amber and
red list countries where people
shouldn't be traveling for holiday so
that's the approach that we're taking
i've seen the proposals that the eu have
put forward in terms of vaccinations at
the moment
not everybody has been vaccinated of
course and
not all adults have been offered the jab
and only
those everybody aged 30 and over
but we do want to make sure that there
is a route to
safe international travel in the future
that's what the global travel task force
has been has been working on
something i work with the transport
secretary the home secretary and the
prime minister on
but at the moment it is the red amber
and green
approach that guides us and i think
that's the right approach
because it means that when a country is
safe
a very very low number of cases no signs
of significant new variance
then we can have relatively
straightforward travel albeit with those
tests which are incredibly important
but for countries which are more at risk
and we can take a more stringent
approach
the next questions from pete from
derby also by video with each new
variant the effectiveness of existing
vaccines becomes
less and less so with the indian variant
spreading
and now a new variant of concern in
yorkshire
why is the government allowing lockdown
relaxation to continue
when most of those who spread the virus
have not yet
even had one vaccination
at thanks pete it's an important
question i'm going to
ask dr harris to uh to set out the
clinical
view from the health security point of
view
but what i'd say first and foremost
is obviously we are working as fast as
we can to get people to have
both jabs it's very important and
thankfully the uptake
is very high but the second thing is
that we monitor these new variants
really really carefully to
check the effectiveness of the vaccines
against them now thankfully the
effectiveness of the
vaccines against the variant first
identified in india that you mentioned
after two jabs does appear to be
effectively the same
as against the old be one seven or the
kent
variant as it was called um and that
means that
we can have confidence in the strategy
that we have
and the strategy that is has been
working but we've of course got to be
vigilant
to these to the number of cases and
critically
how the number of cases translates into
people
ending up in hospital or sadly dying
and so you know the approach we take is
just to be
absolutely transparent about all of this
data set it all out as
dr harris just has done the latest data
and answer as many questions as we can
about it as
uh fully as we can um and uh i'm sure dr
harris is going to improve on my answer
right now
thank you and secretary so the vaccine
effectiveness
uh prior to the uh very the 617.2
uh becoming the predominant one was
around 80 to 90
for both vaccines uh once you've had
second doses
and about 50 for the first um and and
the good news from the report which
public health england
uh published at the weekend was that
actually we're seeing very very strong
vaccine effectiveness after the second
dose
for both the vaccines now it's uh it's
around 80 to 90 percent for the fisa
it's a little bit lower perhaps than
against the kent variant
um and at the moment the data suggests
that the astrozenica one might be a
little bit lower
than again against the variant around 60
but
um it's really important that those
studies they're quite early ones with
quite wide confidence levels so high
high degrees of uncertainty and as we go
forward with more cases
and more numbers they will become
clearer and we're already starting to
see a signal
that the astrozenica effectiveness is
rising in the second dose
so there is a really important message
here which says actually these are good
um but as the as as peter's pointed out
we do have to be really really vigilant
and going back to the first answer
around travel
it's why actually the testing for uh
travelers coming to the country is so
important and the genomic work that we
now do
because we are not only assessing the
risk to uk residents and continuously
searching for new variants
but we're actually helping the rest of
the world understand where those
variants
are at the moment thank you very much
dr harris next question is from laura
koonsberg at the bbc
thank you secretary of state it was
common knowledge last year that there
were terrible problems in care homes
can you still stand there today and say
it's true
that you protected care homes from the
start and did you or did you not
tell downing street that people leaving
care homes would be tested
before they sorry people leaving
hospitals would be tested before they
went back to care homes
[Music]
thanks very much laura we worked as hard
as we could to protect people
in who live in care homes and of course
those who live in care homes
are some of the most vulnerable to this
disease because by its nature
it attacks and has more of an impact
on older people now when it comes to the
testing of people as they left hospital
and went into care homes we committed to
building the testing capacity to allow
that to happen
of course it then takes time to build
testing capacity
in fact one of the critical things we
did was set the 100 000
target back then to make sure we built
that testing capacity and it was very
effective
in doing so and then we were able to
introduce the policy of
testing everybody before going to care
homes but we could only do that once we
had the testing capacity
which i had to build because we didn't
have it in this country from the start
you know we started with a capacity of
less than 2000 in march last year and
and got to 100 000 tests a day
and we set all of this out at the time
in
uh in public documents it's all a matter
of
a public record um and i mean we work
closely together on it
uh jenny um i think i might just add to
that from a professional perspective i
think uh the testing is clearly
important and as secretary of state
has noted uh we have built a lot of
capacity this
this is all uh readily available now we
we do around a million tests a day
but i think actually one of the things
that sometimes gets forgotten in some of
the
conversations about testing is the
really important thing is not
testing says you have a problem the
intervention is very much about
isolation so when an individual leaves
whether it be
a hospital setting the guidance is very
much about
ensuring that there is appropriate
infection prevention control
both in the care home setting but
actually in separating that individual
from others because the test only gives
you the result
on the day the really important thing is
to be able to be sure that a patient
doesn't become
symptomatic and be able to transmit
infection for the subsequent incubation
period
so from an interventional perspective
that is critical testing is really
helpful
um and i think the the only other thing
i would say is it's um
you know the elderly uh who and the
vulnerable in residential settings have
been
a focus actually of a care subgroup in
the sage modelling
group and and actually i chaired that
group specifically to try and understand
precisely
where the risks were predominantly in
residents going into care homes
and because of the very high infection
rates and there were two pieces of work
commissioned
around that and although the data is
quite complex to interpret
it was very clear at the end of this
work
that the there are different ways for
the virus to come into care homes
and it can come from a hospital
discharge but that is definitely not the
majority root of entry it's coming as
community cases rise
and care workers are going in and out as
they do because we need them to provide
care
it's coming in with community rates and
we see that with schools as well
so i think it's just about really
looking at the evidence of where
transmission occurs which is important
thanks very much laura next question is
from carl dineen from itv
secretary of state uh you've explained
why
you didn't test everyone going from
hospital to care home but
the charge from dominic cummings is
actually quite specific and i'd like to
try again
on that did you tell the prime minister
that
everyone going from hospital to care
home would be tested
or is dominic cummings not telling the
truth on that of course
we committed and i committed to
getting the policy in place but it took
time to build the testing you know we
didn't start with a big
testing system in the uk and then
we built that testing system and that's
why the hundred thousand target
was so important because it really
accelerated the
the availability of testing because when
you don't
have much testing we we had to cl
we had to prioritize it according to
clinical need
and so that was the approach that we
took in fact we set all of this
out at the time but you know it is
important
in terms of looking back on it that what
we had to do was
build the testing capacity because there
simply
wasn't at the start of the pandemic that
testing capacity
in place we had to put it in place
and that's the action that i took thanks
very much the next question is from beth
rigby at sky thank you secretary of
state just to follow up on that
uh and specifically mr cummings said
yesterday that you
categorically said in the cabinet room
in march
that people were going to be tested
before
going back into care homes mr cummings
went on to say that he and the prime
minister
subsequently found out that hadn't
happened
he said far from putting a shield around
people they were sent
back to care homes untested so just to
be clear
did you make the statement in march that
they would be
tested before going back to care homes
and that didn't turn out to be true
because you didn't have the testing
system
in place is that what really happened no
i
look there there will be a time when we
go back over all this in great detail
but my recollection of events
is that i committed to delivering
that testing for people going from
hospital into care homes
when we could do it i then went away and
built the testing capacity for all sorts
of reasons and all sorts of uses
including this one
and then delivered on the commitment
that i made and
that is a that's kind of normal way
of how you get things done in government
you work out what needs to happen
you commit to making it happen you go
away and deliver on that commitment
and then you can put the policy in place
and
um you know there'll be a time when we
can go through all this
in greater detail the most important
thing
right now is that we've still got a
pandemic to handle and to manage
and hence the announcements that we're
making today on vaccination
and the work that we're doing to try to
make sure we keep this epidemic under
control
next question is pippa crea from the
mirror people back
am i still sending people back to care
homes untested
did happen during april and is that your
biggest regret
in this pandemic well the thing is
beth on that i mean i've answered this
question many many times
um on that because we didn't have the
testing capacity at the start of the
pandemic
it wasn't possible and
what i am very proud of
is that we built that testing capacity
but it took
time right and it took me setting this
target which people didn't think i was
going to meet
and because of the team effort we did
meet that target and then we had the
testing available
to be able to put the policy in place um
and
i think you know that's that's how
that's how you get things done
and that's how we're still getting
things done for instance
now the big big drive is on making sure
that we get the vaccine rollout
done and there our goal is to make sure
it's offered to all
uh adults by the end of july and we're
on
track for that target too next question
pippa crea
pippa health section we've spoken to
families today who lost their
loved ones coded last spring after
patients were discharged
back into their care homes without being
tested one said she cried when she heard
dominick cummings testimony
and she said i will not be the only one
crying because it reminds you of the
disaster
particularly when he was talking about
not having a plan for care homes and
although he lost her mum told us
nothing he said surprised me at all it
just shows the general chaos and lack of
information in government
i feel that my mum is one of the tens of
thousands of people who didn't need to
die
and the third lost his dad and he said
it was absolute chaos
he didn't know what they were doing as
we all know the buck stops with our
prime minister
he's got ultimate responsibility but i
do hold matt hancock
responsible as well there have been
thirty six thousand
two hundred and seventy five deaths
involving covered in uk care home since
the pandemic began
you promised to put a protective ring
them but you didn't and yet today
you dodged questions from the media from
mps about some of the specifics and now
you're doing it from the media why
whenever clearly wasn't sufficient
sufficient testing capacity
to do it safely did you sign off the
discharge plan
can you give families the answers and
finally give them the peace
that they deserve well thank you pippa
i've been
answering questions all morning and all
afternoon and it's very very important
to
in fact that's been our whole approach
throughout this pandemic
has been to answer questions from
the public and from the media and of
course from
mps and many many people have lost
loved ones as you know you know that
includes my family
um and the truth in the
in this situation is that
because we didn't have the testing
capacity it wasn't possible until we
built that capacity to put
the testing in place and we were dealing
with an
unprecedented situation as you know and
that is one of the things that that
i will always look back on which is that
we worked incredibly hard to put in
place
what is needed to fight a pandemic
and thankfully now over the last few
months
we've really got these these things in
place the
the over a million tests a day on a
regular basis
and of course the vaccine which we've
been working on
since the start so of course my heart
goes out to all those
who've lost loved ones but all i can say
is that we worked to do everything we
possibly could
in what were difficult circumstances
on the details of the of the policy
and why it was in place and crucially
what we've learned is including for
instance on the
uh the asymptomatic transmission of the
of the virus
the fact it passes on people who don't
have any symptoms
we have developed and improved
our policy towards care homes as the
testing capacity
has grown and maybe on the clinical side
dr harris will be able to
uh to address those parts of the
question um yes thank you secretary
i i think um i mean obviously for any uh
i think
you know my family as well uh has lost
somebody at the start of pandemic so
i think we we do feel for those families
if i just go back to uh the evidence and
this is going to sound quite
clinical and scientific but that's what
i've been asked to do
actually uh one of the reasons that the
subgroup the sage subgroup was set up
was
to really try and look at what were the
reasons for these very significant rates
of infection
and death in residential care settings
and it was set up in a way to be able to
feed back
directly to the adult social care policy
plan
in order to be able to implement
findings as quickly as possible
and if you look at the death rates um
and bear in mind of the evidence we
found from
the fact that the discharge from
hospitals was actually
a very very tiny proportional cause
of cases what has had a huge impact
is the testing of a regular testing of
staff and residents now
actually for staff who do this on a
regular basis
it's it's quite time consuming for them
so i'm a huge thank you to them because
every week they do a pcr test
and they do two lateral flow device
tests and if you look at the second wave
what you can see is
that allows this regular testing means
not only do we know
if somebody comes in and has a positive
test before they start work
they don't come into care into the the
setting so they are
no risk of passing on that infection to
others and equally of course we've had
vaccination programs
but the the lateral flow testing has
been a really important
part of just keep an eye on that the pcr
testing allows us to
run at the same time is more sensitive
so we're doing it doubly and checking to
see about variant access
and and we can get on top of these
things much more quickly now
thanks very much uh next question is
from steve swimford at the time
steve it wasn't sufficient testing
capacity why when it clearly wasn't
sufficient testing capacity
did you sign off the discharge plan
um i i'm terribly sorry i'm not sure
that i got the full question but i think
what you're saying is
um that since the challenge was the
testing capacity
um why did you have the plan well
firstly we took clinical advice on what
the appropriate thing to do was
that was the best way to proceed in
these circumstances
but critically you've got to build the
testing capacity
and that's what we did and
and and we published these uh all these
plans at the time
and discussed it in fact we discussed it
at press conferences
uh at the time uh what is the the best
way to approach it
and that's something on which uh we took
the clinical advice
thanks steve swinford at the times
mr hancock have you spoken to the prime
minister about the evidence given by
dominic cummings yesterday in which he
accused you of being a serial liar
and has boris johnson personally given
you his reassurance that he has
confidence in you
as his health secretary um and dr harris
on the on the roadmap professor neil
ferguson said this morning that the
easing of lockdown restrictions on the
21st of june
is very much in the balance given the
rate at which the indian variant is
spreading
do you agree with him on that well the
prime minister and i talk all the time
and we're working incredibly hard on
getting this vaccine roll out as
broad as possible making sure people get
their second doses
and obviously very vigilant to the in
particular to the areas of the country
where
cases are starting to rise as i've set
out so that is
uh that's that's what we focus on
because that is what
really matters to getting this country
out of this pandemic
i mean you know this isn't over yet
and the in a way the rise in case rates
in the last couple of days demonstrate
that we've all got to be vigilant and
we've still
all of us got to take personal
responsibility for what we
can do to help keep this under control
as we get the vaccine rolled out it is a
race between the two
and that's what we're focused on um
jenny
yeah so on the the road map i absolutely
agree with uh with professor neil
ferguson that the roadmap works on on
four principles to go forward so it's on
uh on the cases uh hospitalizations uh
the effectiveness of the vaccine program
and then new variants and so in many
ways we're looking at the first part
and the last part and if you just look
at the pure data which is out today
it looks quite worrying so we had 3535
cases of the
of the 617.2
last week and we have just about double
that 6959 now
however what is important when i
mentioned when i was doing the slides is
we are actively going out and finding
cases so we do expect cases to rise
we also expected some cases to uh to
rise as we
gradually start to socialize um and
i think what's important is when you
look at where these patterns of cases
are
if for example you look at london data
recently where there's been a huge
effort
in in all of these areas actually but in
surge testing and
the faster speed that we can detect new
variants using
uh different techniques and genomic
testing um
in some areas they have closed down so
we haven't seen
we've seen a bit of community
transmission and then it's closed down
again
now the biggest area probably is is
north west as we know and i know
uh the bolton team are working really
hard and also in the
greater manchester area to try and
maintain these numbers quite
low so i think it is really really just
on the cusp at the moment
uh if we see cases rise we are not clear
yet uh
quite whether that is a rise in the
variant cases
um or uh taking off or whether it's
actually
arise because we are actively quite
rightly detecting them and then
challenging these chains of transmission
so really important thing on on the good
news of course we are not seeing that
generally
translating into increased cases of
hospitalization and definitely not
into deaths and and so obviously the the
key message is there
even if we can just hold it while the
vaccination program gets rolled out
we stand a much better chance of getting
through this this
session so my my simple message which is
where i started is
please go and get your job and
particularly if you've got a second job
due shortly
thanks very much i mean that last point
is the absolutely critical one
for the country which is we are in a
race between the virus and this vaccine
the vaccine is effective
so we've got to get the vaccine out as
quickly as possible and that is the
thing that really really matters
uh final question is from jen williams
from the manchester evening news jen
thanks a question to the health sec
truth that's okay um manchester and
trafford's health and social care system
started testing all care home residents
before discharge in the middle of march
2020
because they knew then that there was a
risk and so they found a way to do it
so why did it not become national policy
for another month and do you wish you'd
taken more advice from local public
health and social care leaders at the
start of the pandemic
and one for dr harris there's obviously
been a lot of national attention on
bolton
in the last few weeks and there are
signs that infection rate
rises that are now slowing thanks to the
measures that have been taken
um but those in most other greater
manchester boroughs are now rising very
fast
should these places now be getting
similar military surge vaccination
support to bolton
thanks thanks very much the you know
come back to the earlier point
unfortunately we didn't have the testing
capacity to put that policy in place
across the whole country
you know it would have been wonderful if
we'd started this pandemic with a very
large testing capacity
we didn't we had to build one and
that then once we built one we were able
to put that policy in place
nationwide and when it comes to bolton
there are some early signs
that the increase in rates may be
starting to cap out
we did see this this
program of surge testing plus surge
vaccinations work in south london
and i'm but i'm but i'm really really
watching the the bolton rates uh very
closely
um dr harris thank you um
yes so i might just do a call out here
for the director of public health in
bolton helen towie who has been
absolutely brilliant in supporting this
and we work very closely with her
um i think the as secretary said the
cases actually do look as though they
are
starting to plateau out um but uh the
spillover and community transformation
in local areas is an
important one what we are finding in a
lot of places though that it's not
actually what we would call generalized
transmission that you can still see
focal points of outbreaks whether it be
a community centre whether it be a
school or a faith building
um and so it's really important that
that local
understanding is brought into the
picture so that we can
surge the testing and put in support in
those areas
um i i think actually the way that test
and trace are now working
swiveling around that services and
building from the local system
is a really important one and we're
doing that generally right across areas
looking out for other parts of greater
manchester
to see how we can support them but the
data at the moment is
and those uh those uh support uh
enablers for
full local people are very much focused
on the areas where we can see the rate
of change the rate of growth
uh in transmission is the greatest uh
but we'll continue to watch that
obviously
thanks very much i mean if i can i just
add one other thing jen which is that
you know people in bolton have really
stepped up and i'm very very
grateful um and you can see it in the
queues of
people getting vaccinated big increase
in numbers of vaccinations
the big increase in testing and people
coming forward to get tested
i think the council have done a
brilliant job and their leader david
greenall
is doing a great job as well as the
director of public health um
and we are we will keep supporting
bolton
and we're also watching very carefully
uh
other areas because if this package of
support works effectively against this
variant in bolton
then it's a model for how we can tackle
it without having to resort to a local
lockdown
which obviously nobody wants to see so
that
it's um so far so good but
stick at it bolton we'll get there and
that ends
this downing street press conference
thanks very much
and there we are then matt hancock the
health secretary leading
today's downing street briefing for
those interested lasted about
40 minutes in total he was joined by
jenny harris
chief executive of the uk health
security agency will turn to the
uh political fallout in a moment first
though let me uh state the figures that
have been brought out there and this is
specifically uh the indian variant
up to three quarters of all new
coronavirus
cases being diagnosed now are of the
india variant public health england
figures
uh now six thousand nine hundred
and cases in
total have been diagnosed and that
is double uh the figure uh
confirmed from last week so worrying
levels there
it seems also matt hancock said that
13 200 total
number of deaths have been prevented by
vaccines and 39
000 hospitalizations he went on to say
4.1
million vaccines have been administered
in the past week and that is the highest
since march we heard from jenny harry's
too that
the average over the past seven days
of the number of fatalities from
coronavirus
now stands at eight so well down
on january so some figures for us
there but all the headlines joe pike
joins me now
is going to be on really matt hancock
dodging questions i lost count how many
times he was asked perhaps
seven uh twice by uh beth rigby
did he lie to the prime minister and
this of course on the back of what
dominic
dominic cummings had to say uh yesterday
we were
categorically told in march that people
would be tested
before they went back to care homes
uh but nothing from matt hancock to say
whether or not he lied to the prime
minister
nikki employed the exact uh strategy he
used in the commons earlier very
specific questions but very general
broad answers that though was i think
the toughest
public appearance of matt hancock's
political career perhaps that was
bruising he got a battering partly
because he wasn't
uh straight with people as he's claimed
he has been
there was that key question about care
homes people being discharged from
hospitals without tests it was only
when the third journalist brought back
that same question
our political editor beth rigby that he
sort of
semi answered it didn't talk about what
he said
in the cabinet room to the prime
minister but said he committed to
deliver
testing when we could do it uh
we had to look in uh deep there will be
a time he said to look in detail to it
that is not now
and of course we should say it is fair
that this was unprecedented there were
problems with
asymptotic transmission that we didn't
realize at the time
but matt hancock was dodging question
after question
that is not sustainable in the long term
particularly in terms of the public
inquiry but there is this real conundrum
around dominic cummings for the
government if you
asked very specific questions about
those specific allegations yesterday
it's difficult to give specific answers
because mr cummings may have more
evidence that could prove you wrong
those in government clearly do not want
to
anger mr cummings for fear of
retaliation
but also it's very hard for them to
attack the character
of a man who was appointed to such a
senior position at the heart of the
government
at the heart of so many key projects in
boris johnson's premiership
like the election like brexit and like
uh the pandemic response i think we
should also talk about some of the
key covert headlines from that um
hancock saying perhaps in an attempt to
distract from the comings headlines that
cases
are rising as you pointed out up to
three quarters of cases are now
of the india variant he argued
that there is data that 13 200 deaths
have been prevented due to the rollout
of the vaccine but
critics would perhaps point to what
dominick cummings said yesterday
that tens of thousands more lies could
have been saved
if the government had moved further and
faster
also one i think very significant
omission from
jenny harris on step four of england's
route out of lockdown earlier today
professor neal ferguson said
that step four uh is in the balance
jenny harris nick
saying that she agrees with him that is
a very important date
the 21st of june especially for the
hospitality
sporting entertainment and arts
industries that is the moment they think
that they would be able to open to full
capacity
restaurants we'll be able to get rid of
that a limit of six people have
larger bookings i think that does now a
hang in the balance we've had hesitation
from boris johnson today who said we may
need to wait
now jenny harry's backing up neil
ferguson saying
that this is in the balance joe going
back to matt hancock and what he said
and didn't say many people will look at
what he's been saying in the last
uh 40 minutes pretty evasive can he
survive all this
i think he can what i think boy johnson
will not want to do
at this stage has looked like he is
changing his top team
in response to dominic cummings dominic
cummings partly
left downing street because boris
johnson thought i think that he was
too powerful it would be a sort of win
for dominic cummings if mr hancock were
to be removed
from office and from such a significant
position
dominic cummings has almost unwittingly
strengthened matt hancock's position
because the boris johnson i don't think
will want to be tina's being
pushed around by and influenced by his
uh
former chief advisor but let's be clear
dominic cummings made a lot of very
specific as yet unproven but specific
allegations yesterday he may well have
the evidence in emails in text messages
in contemporaneous notes to prove some
of them maybe he'll never prove them
but if he does prove some of them it
could get very difficult
for matt hancock he is perhaps wisely in
the commons being quite general because
of course if you mislead the commons
convention dictates you may need to
leave your job
but i think matt hancock is very clearly
damaged by the
past couple of days his career in the
future months
looks uncertain but i think immediately
nick borisconsel will not want to get
rid of him partly because it'll look
like
he's uh following uh dominic cummings
and that's something i don't think
you'll want to do at all
all right germany thanks indeed for now
back to you a little later well
keppelgate care home in lancashire took
matters into their own hands
and developed their own regular testing
system for residents and family
well before the government launched its
testing scheme in
care homes last november well their care
and quality lead adam pannell
joins me now good evening to you did you
listen to matt hancock
there he was sort of dodging wasn't he
the the central allegation on whether he
lied
to the prime minister but i mean we knew
that people were not getting tested once
they left hospital
and going into care homes there's
nothing new there
oh no i mean anyone who works in social
care has someone who lives
in social care or is living in social
care themselves knows for a fact that
up until may last year we were being
told testing wasn't a requirement for
people
moving into care homes from hospital but
you know we were being told we were
being protected but
every single webinar we were having we
were told it